ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
BAUER-KAHAN [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BURNER **** BATH [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON [inaudible] ZERO
CERVANTES.
CHAO [inaudible]
CHEN [inaudible]
DAVID CHIU [inaudible]
CHOI.
KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALLY [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
FLORA [inaudible]
PHONE [inaudible]
FRAZIER [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GABRIEL [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
[inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
GLORIA.
GONZALEZ.
GRAY [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
LEVINE [inaudible]
LEóN [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
MAYES [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
MELENDEZ [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
MURATSUCHI.
THIS AREA IN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS [inaudible]
QUIRK [inaudible]
WORK SILVA [inaudible]
RAMOS.
RAY IS LOOSE REBA US.
ROBERT REAVIS.
RODRIGUEZ[inaudible]
RUBIO.
SALAS SANTIAGO.
SMITH [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
TEEN [inaudible]
VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON [inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
WICKS.
WORD.
MISTER SPEAKER
.
YEAH HEY READY I MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
REVEREND PATTY OSHA REPETITION.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE OF
NINETEEN FIFTEEN THE JEWISH
HOLOCAUST DURING WORLD WAR.
TWO THE CAMBODIAN GENOCIDE IN
THE MID NINETEEN SEVENTIES.
EVERYONE.
GENOCIDE OF NINETEEN NINETY FOUR
WE'RE 70% OF THE TUTSIS
POPULATION WERE KILLED.
SADLY THE LIST OF ATROCITIES IS
NOT SHORT.
EACH WAS A NIGHTMARE SO
UNTHINKABLE THEY DEFY
DESCRIPTION.
EACH MARKS A TIME IN HUMAN
HISTORY.
WHEN SELFISH ARROGANCE SEIZE
POWER?
AND GOVERNMENTS FEEL PEOPLE'S
HEART WITH HATRED.
EACH TIME HUMAN DECENCY WAS
BURIED BY HATEFUL RAGE THE ALLOW
THOSE IN POWER TO JUSTIFY THEIR
CALCULATED CAMPAIGNS OF
UNIMAGINABLE CRUELTY.
THIS PAST EASTER SUNDAY IN SHEER
LANKA.
HATE FILLED ARROGANCE AGAIN
ATTEMPTED TO PREVAIL IS THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE PEOPLE
WERE KILLED.
IN COORDINATED EXPLOSIONS.
THE PERPETRATORS CLAIM THAT THE
BOMBINGS WERE IN RETALIATION FOR
THE ATTACK OF MONTH ON MUSLIMS
IN CHRISTCHURCH.
JUST LAST MONTH.
BUT THIS POOR ATTEMPT TO JUSTIFY
MASS MURDER ONLY REVEALS HOW
ARROGANCE AND HATE. TO OFTEN TRY
TO DISGUISE THEM SIGN THEMSELVES
AS RIGHTEOUS CRUSADE.
WE MUST NEVER FORGET THAT WE
HUMAN BEINGS.
WE ARE SO MUCH BETTER THAN THIS.
THE WISDOM OF MAHATMA GANDHI
CONTINUES TO RING TRUE.
WE MUST NOT LOSE FAITH IN
HUMANITY.
AND I FOR AN I WILL LEAVE THE
WHOLE WORLD BLIND.
WE CANNOT GROW NUMB TO SUCH
VIOLENCE.
WE CANNOT ALLOW SELF RIGHTEOUS
ARROGANCE BLIND US FROM SEEING
THAT WE ARE NOT SEPARATE FROM
EACH OTHER.
ALTHOUGH AT TIMES WE MAY DESPAIR.
WE MUST NEVER LOSE FAITH.
IN THE GOODNESS OF OUR SHARED
HUMANITY.
NOW MORE MENDOZA.
WITH KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE
BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND OUR STAFF WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE.
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO ISSUE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER PLEASE
JOIN ME IN HONORING OUR NATION'S
FLAG REPEAT AFTER ME I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
[inaudible]
YEAH.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
TUESDAY APRIL SECOND TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN IS FROM ABOUT
AT SEVEN AM THE AUDIBLE BRIAN
DAHLE ASSEMBLYMEMBER VERSUS OUR
PRESIDING SHE FLIRTED ALSO WAS
IN THE DESK.
READING LOOK AT ME AND WAS
READING THE FOLLOWING A PLACE ON
THE MORNING ROLL CALL
AGUIAR-CURRY BAUER-KAHAN BERMAN
BIGELOW BLOOM BURN A WHOLE RAFT.
BONTA BROUGH BURKE CALDERON
CARRILLO CERVANTES CHAU CHEN
CHIU CHOI CHU COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALY DALY DEEP EGGMAN
FLORA FONG FRAZIERFRIEDMAN
CABLE GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA.
GARCIA GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ
GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LIMON LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY
MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
RESEARCHING IS ERIN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS.
QUIRK RAMOS RACE THREE OF US
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH'S OWN TING
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WORKS WITH
MISTER SPEAKER A QUORUM PRESENT
AT TWELVE TEN PM ON A ROB BONTA
ã THINK JUST CITING.
REGULAR BUSINESS PLANS WITH BY
UNANIMOUS CONSENT THE REGULAR
ORDER BUSINESS OF THE ASSEMBLY
WAS THIS RESIDENCE FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE DAY LEAVES OF
ABSENCE FOR THE DAY BY UNANIMOUS
CONSENT PROBLEM ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
ARE GRANTED LEAVES OF ABSENCE
FOR THE DAY.
A LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK SILVA BECAUSE
WILSON'S FAMILIES MEMBER WOULD
WATER SEAL LEAVE OF ABSENCE
RATED WITH THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE.
THE FOLLOWING INFORMATION
BUSINESS OR PRINT ZERO HELLO
MISTER CALDERON MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS THAT THE READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS TODAY'S ABSENCES WE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY FOR
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS GARCIA AND CHEN FOR
ILLNESS.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTIONS
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUSCONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE WHEN
EIGHTEEN EIGHT ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY. TO HAVE
GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE
FLOOR ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY'S
GUEST WILL BE SEATED AT HIS DESK
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY WILL
FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY
TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO RE REFER THE FOLLOWING BILLS
COMMITTEE AB THIRTY SIX BLOOM
FROM THE HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE.
AB SEVEN FORTY TWO CERVANTES
FROM THE REVENUE AND TAXATION
COMMITTEE TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
AB TEN FIFTY FIVE LEVINE FROM
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE AB FORTY SEVENTY
NINE CERVANTES FROM THE REVENUE
TAXATION COMMITTEE TO THE
PREPARATIONS COMMITTEE.
AND AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
LEVINE FROM THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES COMMITTEE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER [inaudible]
YEAH.
YOUR GALLAGHER FOR WHAT PURPOSE
DO YOU RISE.
MADAM SPEAKER I ASK UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO WITHDRAW AB SIX SIX
FIVE FROM THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMUNITY COMMITTEE AND MOVE IT
TO SECOND READING ON THE FLOOR.
MISTER CALDERON OF JACK'S.
WITH A SECOND FOR MISTER DOLLARS
MISSION.
MR MATHIS SECOND THE MOTION.
THIS IS NOT AVAILABLE WILL TAKE
A ROLL CALL VOTE ON YOUR MISTER
YOUR MISSION MISTER GALLAGHER.
TAKES FORTY ONE VOTES TO HAVE
YOUR THE CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR
OWN.
MISTER GALLAGHER IS ASKING FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE MISTER CALDERON IS
ASKING FOR YOUR NO VOTE.
WE ARE TAKING A VOTE ON MR
GALLAGHER'S MOTION MISTER
GALLAGHER ASKS FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
MISTER CALDERON ASKS FOR YOUR NO
VOTE.
IF YOU READ [inaudible]
THIS MEASURE
.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE.
SORRY MR GALLAGHER MOTION FAILS.
AYE AYES FORTINOS.
FORTY EIGHT WHAT WERE MISTER
GALLAGHER PLEASE STATE YOUR
POINT OF ORDER.
I BELIEVE THAT -- THAT MOTION IS
DEBATABLE.
AS IS A MOTION TO A PROCEDURAL
MOTION TO BRING A BILL TO THE
FLOOR.
I'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO STATE MY
REASONS YOU KNOW FOR FOR
BRINGING IT.
FOR MOTIONS TO SUSPEND THE RULES
ARE NOT TO BE HONEST --
GALLAGHER THANK YOU
.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO BUSINESS
ON THE DAILY FILE.
ASSEMBLY SECOND READING FILE
ITEMS ONE THROUGH ONE FORTY SIX
THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE FORTY SIX NINE
TWENTY SIXTEEN NINETY FIVE WITH
A MINUTE SEVENTEEN ON I WITH HIM
IT'S ELEVEN SIXTY ONE WITH A
MINUTES OF FORTY SIX OF THE
MEMBERS FOURTEEN SIXTY FIVE THE
MINUTES. FIFTEEN SIXTY FIVE
FIFTEEN FIFTY THREE TWELVE
TWENTY ONE ELEVEN NINETY WITH A
MINUTES ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE OF THE
MAIN AT SEVEN TWENTY ONE OF THE
MEMBERS A TWELVE THE MEMBERS TEN
TWENTY TWO THE MINUTES. SIXTEEN
AWAY WITH A MEMBERS TO NINETY
SIX THE MINUTE SIX TWENTY SEVEN
WITH A MEMBERS FOURTEEN THIRTY
SIX OF THE MINUTE SEVEN SEVEN
ARE WITH MINUTES. THIRTEEN SIXTY
FOUR WITH A MEMBERS ONE TWENTY
SIX OF THEM IN A SMALL PARTY TO
THE MINUTES WHILE SIXTY TWO OF
THE MEMBERS SEVEN TWENTY FOUR
MINUTES. SIXTEEN SEVENTY TWO OF
THE MEMBERS SIXTEEN SIXTY WITH A
MEMBERS FOURTEEN UNDER WITH
AMENDMENTS 1-814-340-6110
1-602-153-5660 FOUR THIRTEEN
FIFTY THREE FIFTY WITH A MEMBERS
TOLD TWENTY TO THE MEMBERS WILL
SEVENTY FIVE THE MEMBERS.
ALREADY SIX OF THE MINUTES
EIGHTEEN IS GIVE ME A
1-461-413-6050 TWO SIXTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN THE MEMBERS THREE
SIXTY TWO THE MEMBERS TO
AFFECTING WITH A MEMBERS THREE
SEVEN ABLE TO MEMBERS FIGHTING I
WITH HIM IT'S 342-072-40260
729-330-5360. 1-398-440-7403
458-407-4084 985-045-4035 FORTY
EIGHT FIVE SIXTY SIX SIX AWAIT
640-968-6709 710-714-7277
367-407-7547 617-586-86490
298-903-1000 1-037-104-0410
EIGHTY FOUR ELEVEN TWENTY NINE
SEVENTY THREE WITH A MEMBERS.
FIFTEEN FIFTY THREE ELEVEN
SEVENTY NINE TWELVE THIRTEEN
TWELVE THIRTY FIVE TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN TWELVE FORTY TWELVE NINETY
FOUR THIRTEEN NINETEEN THIRTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTEEN SEVENTY
TWO THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR
THIRTEEN NINETY TWO FOURTEEN
FOURTEEN FOURTEEN SEVENTY THREE
FOURTEEN NINETY THREE FIFTEEN
FOURTEEN SIXTEEN TWENTY TO
SIXTE.
MINUTES 292-321-3337 SEVEN FOUR
SIXTY SEVEN FORTY FIVE FIVE OR
652-858-5605 634-695-7068
819-239-29930 TWO NIGHTS OF THE
510-329-29111 231-124-1250 ONE
TOLL 614-021-40714 --
231-541-66917 881-819-1530 SEVEN
WITH A MEMBER IT'S AN ASSEMBLY
RULES NINE FIFTY SIX OF THE
MINUTES.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS WITH US
IN THE ASSEMBLY TODAY.
MR MEDINA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GUEST INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
PLEASE HELP ME AND WALK ME
DOCTOR JUDY WHY.
THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS.
DR WHITE OVERSEES THE COUNTY'S
PRESCHOOL.
THROUGH TWELFTH GRADE EDUCATION
SYSTEM.
THE FOURTH LARGEST IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
SERVING MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THOUSAND STUDENTS.
DOCTOR WHY IS THE TWELFTH
ELECTED SUPERINTENDENT. FOR
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND IS THE
FIRST WOMAN AND FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN TO SERVE IN THIS ROLE.
DOCTOR WHITE HAS WORKED AS A
CLASSIFIED EDUCATOR.
TEACHER PRINCIPAL ASSISTANT
SUPERINTENDENT DEPUTY
SUPERINTENDENT AND SAMBAR TO DO
YOU KNOW CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
AND SUPERINTENDED OF MORENO
VALLEY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
DOCTOR WHITE IS HERE TODAY WITH
HER GRANDDAUGHTER NICOLE SPOCK
SPAULDING.
MEMBERS PLEASE HELP ME IN
WELCOMING DR JUDY WHITE TO THE
ASSEMBLY.
THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA MISTER
MCCARTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GUEST INTERACTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER ONCE
AGAIN I'M EXCITED TO WELCOME MY
DAUGHTER'S TO WORK WITH ME THEY
THEY CERTAINLY COME HERE EVERY
NOW AND THEN BUT THIS IS TAKE
YOUR DAUGHTER TAKE YOUR KID TO
WORK DAY.
SO WITH ME TODAY FIRST OF ALL IF
IN THE GALLERY IS THE OTHER TWIN.
VICTORIA MCCARTY AND ON MY DESK
HERE IS BARBARA MCCARTY THEIR
FOURTH GRADERS HERE AT PHOEBE
HEARST ELEMENTARY LEARNING ABOUT
THE WORK AND THEY HAD A CHANCE --
TO BARBARA'S WORKING ON
ASSIGNMENT TODAY SHE'S DOING A
PROJECT ON WATER HYACINTHS AS
YOU HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
INTERVIEW OUR COLLEAGUE OVER
HERE FROM OAKLEY. TO LEARN ABOUT
THE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS OF
WATER HYACINTH IN OUR IN OUR
ADULT IN OUR WATER HUESO AGAIN
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING MY
DAUGHTER'S TO WORK ONCE AGAIN
THANK YOU
.
MEMBERS MOVING TO THE ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING [inaudible]
FILE.
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN SIXTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS AN
ACCOLADE HEALTHCARE COVERAGE.
IS PETRIE-NORRIS YOU MAY OPEN ON
YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR AB.
TEN SIXTY THREE THE PURPOSE OF
THIS SPELL IS TO SHORE UP THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AGAINST ON GOING.
YES MISTER CALDERON THEY GET
IT'S VERY LOUD CAN WE PLEASE
GIVE RESPECT AND IN ATTENTION TO
OUR COLLEAGUE WILL SEE PRESENTS
A BILL.
YES MEMBERS THAT WE ORDER IN THE
CHAMBER PLEASE GIVE YOUR RESPECT
TO MS PETRIE-NORRIS ISSUE
PRESENTS THIS IMPORTANT BELL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS.
AS I SAID I THE PURPOSE OF THIS
BILL IS TO SHORE UP THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AGAINST ONGOING
FEDERAL AT TIMES TOO WEEKEND THE
ACA.
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE
LEGISLATIVE APPROVAL AND THE
STATE CHANGE IN STATUTE PRIOR TO
MAKING ANY CHANGES TO THE COVER
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM THROUGH THE
USE OF THIRTEEN THIRTY TWO
WAIVERS.
JUST A BRIEF BACKGROUND AND
THIRTEEN THIRTY TWO WAIVERS THEY
ALLOW A STATE TO WAIT EXTENSIVE
PORTIONS OF THE AFFORDABLE CARE
ACT.
INCLUDING THE RULES REGARDING
THE REGULATION OF QUALIFIED
HEALTH PLANS COST SHARING
REDUCTIONS IN PREMIUM TAX
CREDITS AND THE INDIVIDUAL AND
EMPLOYER MANDATES.
AS PART OF ITS STRATEGY TO
UNDERMINE THE AFFORDABLE CARE
ACT IN OCTOBER OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION RELEASED NEW
FEDERAL GUIDELINES ON THE
INTERPRETATION OF THIRTEEN
THIRTY TWO WAIVERS
THIS REINTERPRETATION
DRAMATICALLY RELAXES WAIVER
GUARD RAILS THREATENS
PROTECTIONS FOR PEOPLE WITH PRE
EXISTING CONDITIONS AND ALLOWS
STATES TO PURSUE THIRTEEN THIRTY
TWO WAIVERS WITH.
LEGISLATIVE APPROVAL INSTEAD
WAIVERS CAN NOW BE AUTHORIZED
HER STATE REGULATION OR AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER.
IN CALIFORNIA AS YOU WELL KNOW
THE LEGISLATURE PLAYED A KEY
ROLE IN THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT AND THIS
BODY TO CONTINUE TO PLAY A KEY
ROLE IN.
ANY.
MEANINGFUL CHANGES AS WE MOVE
FORWARD WELL WE DON'T ANTICIPATE
EIGHT THIRTEEN THIRTY TO WAVER
AT THIS POINT AS WE DO NOTE
MOMENTS CHANGE AND BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT STEP TO
ENSURE THAT WE PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS. TO PROTECT THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I'D
THAT.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER MISSED
EACH UNIVERSITY MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE THAT.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
PLEASE VOTE.
I'M MEMBERS ZERO PLEASE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS WHO DARED -- PLEASE
VOTE.
BECAUSE THEY'RE ALL.
I FIFTY FOUR NOTES ELEVEN THIS
MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS ONE FORTY EIGHT
THROUGH ONE FIFTY TWO OR PAST
RETAINS.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM.
ONE FIFTY THREE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE FOR SIXTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS AN
ACCOLADE AND STATE RECORDS
MANAGEMENT.
YES PETER NORRIS YOU MAY OPEN ON
THIS ITEM THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY FOUR
SIXTY NINE THIS BILL IS
SPONSORED BY THE SECRETARY OF
STATE AND WILL ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE EFFECTIVE AND CONSISTENT
MANAGEMENT OF STATE RECORDS.
I FOR THE SECRETARY OF STATE
STATE ARCHIVE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR EYES THAT.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
PLEASE NOTE.
I'M MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE IT --
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
WHERE QUIRK CLOSE THE ROLE I
SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO THIS MEASURE
PASSES?
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY FOUR IS PASS
AND RETAIN MOVING TO FILE ITEM
ONE FIFTY FIVE AB SIX TWENTY THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE SIX
TWENTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY
INOCULATE LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
MR COOLEY YOU MAY OPEN ON THIS
MATTER.
GOOD AFTERNOON OR GOOD MORNING
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT AB SIX
TWENTY RELATED A SUDDEN
UNEXPLAINED DEATH IN CHILDHOOD.
AND THIS IS A BILL OF PARTICULAR
MEANING TO ME [inaudible]
ALL.
EARLY IN MY CAREER I HAD A
COLLEAGUE IN THIS BUILDING WHO
WITH HIS WIFE LOST A CHILD.
IN WHAT WAS THEN UNKNOWN.
SIX SUDDEN INFANT DEATH IN
CHILDHOOD [inaudible]
AND IN MY DISTRICT I HAVE A
FAMILY.
THAT HAD A CALLING.
MEMBERS PLEASE QUIET DOWN ANY
RESPECT MR COOLEY.
IN MY ASSEMBLY DISTRICT I HAD A
FAMILY WHO LOST THEIR SON HE WAS
VERY ACTIVE IN A LOCAL SCHOOL
LACK OF IN BAND OF MUSICIANS.
WAS OUT WITH FRIENDS CAME HOME
LATE ONE NIGHT -- FIFTEEN YEARS
OLD.
AND THE NEXT MORNING HE WAS A
LITTLE LATE SLEEPER THEN THE
PARENTS WANTED TO CHECK IN ON
THEIR SON AND HE HAD DIED
OVERNIGHT [inaudible]
UTTERLY INEXPLICABLE.
EVERY PERRANCE HORROR. TO WALK
INTO YOUR CHILD SAFE SECURE ROOM
IN THEIR THEIR HAVING PASSED
AWAY IN THE NIGHT.
SAID NOT EXPRESSED DEBT SUDDEN
UNEXPLAINED DEATH IN CHILDHOOD
IS NOT NEW IT IS VERY RARE.
AN ESTIMATED ONE POINT TWO
DEATHS PER HUNDRED THOUSAND
CHILDREN.
CURRENTLY IN ANY CASE WE'RE IN
IT ANY INFANT UNDER TWELVE DOT
UNDER AGE OF TWELVE MONTHS DICE.
TO DO SAID.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOU RESPECT
MR COOLEY.
CURRENTLY FOR CHILD UNDER TWELVE
MONTHS OF AGE DIES UNDERSTANDS
[inaudible]
THE LAW REQUIRES AT THE CORNER
NOTIFY THE PARENTS OF THE
IMPORTS ARE GETTING TISSUE
SAMPLES.
SO THE COURSE OF TIME THERE CAN
BE SOME EFFORT TO ASCERTAIN WHAT
TRANSPIRED.
THAT REQUIREMENT DOES NOT EXIST
FOR SUDDEN UNEXPLAINED DEATH IN
CHILDHOOD.
IT IS STRONGLY RECOMMENDED UNDER
FEDERAL GUIDELINES.
AB SIX TWENTY SIMPLY TO FIND
SOME NOOKS BRAIN DEATH IN
CHILDHOOD IN STATUTE.
AND REQUIRES CORNERS TO INFORM
THE PARENT OR GUARDIAN OF A
CHILD WHO DIES UNDER SUCH
CIRCUMSTANCES.
ABOUT THE IMPORTS OF TISSUE
SAMPLES IT IS A VERY SOUND
POLICY.
IT IS A COMPANION TO WHAT WE
ALREADY DO IS SINCE.
I URGE ARRIVAL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS ART OF A ON
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
I'M MEMBERS VOTED DESIRED ABOUT.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO THIS MEASURE
PASSES
.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE
FIFTY SIX AB EIGHT NINETY THREE
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT NINETY THREE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA
ANOTHER'S AN ACCOLADE
AGRICULTURAL DISTRICTS.
MR GLORIA YOU MAY OPEN ON THIS
MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I BRING BEFORE YOU ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT NINETY THREE THIS IS A
DISTRICT BILL THE BILL IS A
RESPONSE TO THE OVERWHELMING
CALL FROM MY CONSTITUENTS THAT
ARE.
DISTRICTS AGRICULTURAL
ASSOCIATION THE TWENTY SECOND
AGRICULTURAL DISTRICT STOP
SELLING GUNS AND AMMUNITION ON
STATE PROPERTY.
AS MEMBERS OF THIS BODY ARE NOT
A NO DOUBT AWARE THE GATE THE
PLAGUE OF GUN VIOLENCE IS THAT
NEAR IN NEARLY EVERY CORNER OF
OUR STATE.
JUST LAST YEAR FORTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE DIE FROM GUNS THE UNITED
STATES THE HIGHEST RATE IN FIFTY
YEARS.
BERG AND REGRETTABLY NOT A WEEK
GOES BY WHERE ANOTHER SENSELESS
TRAGEDY INVOLVING GUNS DOES NOT
OCCUR.
FORTUNATELY. FOR US IN THIS
CHAMBER TODAY WE WERE SENT HERE
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT PROBLEMS
LIKE THIS WE HAVE AN ACTIVE
ENGAGED CITIZENRY THAT IS HOW
THE WIND BEHIND OUR BACKS.
ACCORDING TO THE STUDY BY THE
SAN DIEGO ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS CRIMINAL JUSTICE
CLEARING HOUSE NEARLY THREE
QUARTERS 73% OF ALL HOMICIDES IN
OUR COMMUNITY.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN INVOLVED A
FIRE ARM THE SAN DIEGO REGION
ALONE JUST OVER HALF 53% OF ALL
HOMICIDES INVOLVED A GUN.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT MORE THAN
OFFERING THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS
MEMBERS THIS BILL IS ABOUT
ACTION AB ONE EIGHT NINETY THREE
WOULD PROHIBIT THE SALE OF GUNS
AMMUNITION AT THIS DEL MAR
FAIRGROUNDS.
A STATE OWNED AND RUN FACILITY
THAT IS HOME TO MANY OTHER
POPULAR CULTURAL CONCERTS AND
EVENTS.
IT'S IMPORTANTNOT TO THIS BILL
WILL STILL ALLOW FOR THE
EDUCATIONAL AND PROMOTION OF GUN
SAFETY AS LONG AS GUNS
AMMUNITION ARE NOT SOLD.
THIS BILL IS A DIRECT RESPONSE
TO THE OVERWHELMING CALL FROM MY
CONSTITUENTS IN THE CITIES OF
DEL MAR ENCINITAS ANSALON A
BEACH.
IN THE SALE OF GUNS AND
AMMUNITION ON THIS PROPERTY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
THOSE.
THANK YOU THIS BOERNER HORVATH
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I WANNA
SPEAK TODAY IN SUPPORT OF EIGHT
NINETY THREE I WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM SAN DIEGO
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
THIS IS A MUCH LONG OVERDUE BILL --
WHEN I GOT ELECTED THE STATE
ASSEMBLY MY MOTHER GAVE ME A
CALL AND SHE SAID TASHA -- I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR CO
AUTHORING A NINETY THREE SHOULD
TALK ABOUT ANY OF MY BILLS YOU
TALK ABOUT THE FAMILY MEMBERS
AND THIS IS SAN DIEGO AS WELL.
AND SHE SAID GROWING UP AN
INSIDIOUS WE WERE ALWAYS AFRAID
OF THESE GUN SHOWS.
SO I AM SO THANKFUL THAT WE WE
ARE ALLOWING THE EDUCATIONAL
PURPOSE UP FOR GUN SAFETY BUT WE
ARE LIMITING THE AMOUNT OF THE
THE AMMUNITION FEEL.
OF OF FIRE ARMS OUT THE DEL MAR
FAIRGROUNDS SO I WANT TO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH IS THE ONLY MEMBER
OF GLORIA AND I WOULD LIKE.
TO SAY MY STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MISS BOERNER HORVATH.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE YOU MAY CLOSE THIS GLORIA
THANK YOU ON A SPEAKER
APPRECIATE THAT.
MY COLLEAGUE FROM INSIDIOUSNESS
COMMENTS -- MEMBERS THIS IS A
SMALL BUT MEANINGFUL STEP TO
INCREASING SAFETY IN OUR
COMMUNITY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE THOSE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
I'M MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED OF
A ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLL.
EYES FORTY EIGHT NO SIXTEEN THIS
MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS ONE FIFTY SEVEN AND
ONE FIFTY EIGHT PASTOR RETAINS.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY
NINE AB TEN EIGHTY TO THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SOME BUILT IN EIGHTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW AN ACCOLADE
TO GAMBLING.
MR LOW YOU'RE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS THIS IS AB TEN EIGHTY
TWO THE GAMING CONTROL ACT THIS
IS A TECHNICAL NATURE OF A CLEAN
UP.
RECEIVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THEIR OWN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO THAT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THE ART OF
A THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLL
EYES SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO THIS
MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE SIXTY PAST
RETAINS MOVING TO FILE ITEM. ONE
SIXTY ONE MISTER HOLDEN THE
CLERK WILL READ BEFORE MISTER
HOPE NO OFFENSE.
SOME PEOPLE FIFTEEN FORTY WITH A
MINUTES BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDER.
MR HOLDEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT
FLOOR AMENDMENTS FOR ASSEMBLY
BILL.
FIFTEEN FORTY I LIKE TO THINK
THE STAKEHOLDERS WHO HAVE WORKED
WITH US TO DEVELOP AMENDMENTS TO
REFLECT THAT MUSIC THERAPISTS.
CURRENTLY EMPLOYED BY THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA DID NOT NEED TO
OBTAIN CERTIFICATION TO STAY
EMPLOYED.
THIS AMENDMENT REMOVES ALL
OPPOSITION.
AB FIFTEEN FORTY STILL PROHIBITS
ANYONE INCLUDING STATE EMPLOYEES.
WHO IS NOT CERTIFIED TO USE THE
TILE OF BOARDCERTIFIED MUSIC
THERAPIST I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE?
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
IS THERE AN OBJECTION TO VOICE
HEARD ON MR HOLDEN TO
MAINTENANCE WITHOUT OBJECTION
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ALL IN
FAVOR AYE.
I'LL OPPOSE.
THE AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
HOW TO PRINT BACK ON FILE?
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY TWO IS
PASSED TO RETAIN MOVING TO FILE
ITEM ONE SIXTY THREE AB EIGHTEEN
TWENTY ONE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME AGO EIGHTEEN TWENTY ONE BY
THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
INOCULATED CONTRACTS.
MR STONE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS BACK IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE THE FORTY
MINISTRATION PUT A RULE IN PLACE
TO PROTECT CONSUMERS WHO ARE OUT
BUYING -- ITEMS THAT WERE
SUBJECT POTENTIAL FRIED FAIRLY
RECENTLY THE THIRD DISTRICT
COURT OF APPEALS AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL CHANGE THAT RULE THAT HAD
BEEN IN PLACE FOR FORTY YEARS.
THIS IS A COMMITTEE BILL WE'RE
TRYING TO REINSTATE THAT TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS AND I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTES.
MR COOLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS MATTER.
I JUST WANTED KNOWLEDGE THIS IS
A GOOD BUILD GOOD RULE GERALD
FORD WAS NOT PRESENT VERY LONG
HE HE WAS OVERSAW THE ADOPTION
OF THIS.
ALSO OVERSAW THE ADOPTION OF THE
REST OF THE LAW WHICH CONTINUES
TO PLAY IMPORTANT ROLES -- WE
BECAUSE OF THIS SUMMER'S FRAZIER
KARMA SO NOT MANY MONUMENTS TO
GERALD FORD IN OUR STATUTE BUT
THIS IS ONE OF THEM A GOOD BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL THOSE WHO DO THAT THE ART OF
OAKLEY'S VOTE.
ALL THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
PLEASE VOTE.
ALL THOSE WHO THEIR TO VOTE
PLEASE VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK.
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE.
I FIFTY THREE KNOWS SIXTEEN THIS
MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS ONE SIXTY FOUR AND
ONE SIXTY FIVE A PASTOR CHANGE.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY
SIX AB TWO SEVENTY THREE THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO SEVENTY THREE
BY SOME REMEMBER GONZALEZ AND I
RELATED TRAPPING.
MISS GONZALEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AB TWO SEVENTY
THREE THREE WOULD PROHIBIT FOR
TRAPPING FOR A COMMERCIAL
PURPOSE IN THE SALE OF ROB FOR
IN CALIFORNIA.
TODAY FOR TRAPPING CALIFORNIA IS
DONE AN EXTREMELY SMALL SCALE
BRINGS IN VERY LITTLE INCOME TO
THE STATE ONLY ABOUT SIXTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR BUT IN
FACT TO ALLOW CONTINUED
COMMERCIAL FOR TRAPPING ACTUALLY
COSTA STATE IN ORDER TO RUN THE
PROGRAM.
SO WE'RE ACTUALLY SUBSIDIZING
COMMERCIAL FOR TRAPPING
CALIFORNIA NOTHING IN THIS BILL
WOULD PROHIBIT THE TRAPPING OF
ANIMALS WHO ARE A THREAT TO
CROPS WERE A THREAT TO OUR
PERSONAL PROPERTY OR PERSONS.
IT ALSO -- DOES NOT REQUIRE AT
THIS TYPE OF LICENSE TO TRAP
INVASIVE SPECIES SUCH AS NUTRIA
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
MISS EGGMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- MEMBERS AND ABOUT A
SPEAKER KNOBS TALK TO THE AUTHOR
ABOUT THIS IN WE HAVE A LITTLE
DIFFERENCE OF OPINION ON THE THE
ABILITY THEN TO TRAP NUTRIA I
CAN TELL YOU OF MY MY FARMERS
OUT ON THE DELTA LEVEES.
WE'RE THE NUTRIA ARE BORING IN
THE LEVEES AND WHEN THOSE LEVEES
BREAK NOBODY WANTS TO BE
STANDING IN THE WAY.
IS AN INVASIVE SPECIES WE NEED
ALL MEANS AVAILABLE TO BE ABLE
TO A RADIC KATE THEM -- AND IF
ALL MARKET COULD DEVELOP I THINK
WE NEED TO PROVIDE ROOM FOR THAT
TO BE ABLE TO OCCUR AGAIN
MEMBERS ON WITHOUT INVASIVE
SPECIES THAT IS.
COMING FROM OTHER PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY BURROWING INTO OUR
LEVEES THREATENING THE
LIVELIHOOD OF HALF A MILLION
PEOPLE AS WELL AS THE CROPS AND
ECONOMY I THINK WE NEED TO HAVE
ALL MEANS ON THE TABLE.
SO I RESPECTFULLY HAVE TO
DECLINE TO VOTE FOR THIS BILL.
MISTER GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE GENERAL
MINISTRY CROUCHES JOIN WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM STOCKED IN -- YOU
KNOW THERE ARE SOME VERY BAD
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
FROM THIS BILL -- THEY COULD IN
FACT.
A BIT ERROR.
OR IN MANY CASES IMPEDE OUR
ABILITY TO GET OUT INVASIVE
SPECIES THAT ARE CAUSING
PROBLEMS FOR OUR FOR OUR PUBLIC.
SAFETY IN THE CASE OF FLOOD
CONTROL LEVEES -- BUT ALSO IN IN
OUR AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY WHERE
WE DO HAVE INVASIVE PASSED
INVASIVE -- PREDATORY.
ANIMALS THAT DO CAUSE PROBLEMS
FOR CROPS AND OUR ABILITY TO
PROVIDE YOU WITH HEALTHY.
FOOD AND SO I WOULD ASK YOU TO
REALLY CONSIDER THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF THIS BILL AND
ASK YOU EITHER LAY OFFER VOTE
NOW THANK YOU.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER MISS
GONZALES YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU I JUST WANT TO BE
REALLY CLEAR AND I I YOU CAN
GOOGLE NUTRIA IT IS A RODENT
THERE IS NO COMMERCIAL MARKET
FOR INVASIVE SPECIES CALLED
NUTRIA.
AT THE THE PROHIBITION THIS BILL
DOES NOT PRO PROHIBIT ANYONE
FROM CATCHING NUTRIA IN AND THAT
FOR THE PURPOSES OF A RADICALLY
NEW INVASIVE SPECIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS ART OF A
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE A
I'LL
MEMBERS THAT HE DESIRED OF THE
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE.
I FORTY THREE NO SIXTEEN THIS
MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY SEVEN IS
PASSED IN RETAINS.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY
EIGHT AB FOR FIFTY SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE FOR FIFTY SEVEN BY
SOME REMEMBER QUIRK AND OTHERS
AN ACCOLADE THE LEAD EXPOSURE
LEVELS.
MR QUIRK YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
THIS BILL REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT
OF INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS. TO
FINALIZE RECORD REGULATIONS TO
LOWER THE PERMISSIBLE EXPOSURE
LEVEL.
OF FOR LEAD FOR WORKERS BY A
DATE CERTAIN CAL OSHA HAS BEEN
WORKING ON REVISING.
THE LEAD LEVELS SINCE TWENTY
ELEVEN BUT THE REGULATIONS HAVE
YET TO BE UPDATED. EIGHT YEARS
IS TOO LONG TO WAIT.
THE RESEARCH IS DONE THE
ECONOMIC REPORT IS COMPLETE.
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE THE
REGULATIONS. TO BE COMPLETED SO
WE CAN PROTECT WORKERS FROM LEAD
EXPOSURE.
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS NOTES THE CALLOW SHE'S
STAFF -- INDICATES THAT THE RULE
MAKING PROCESS WILL BE COMPLETED
BY FEBRUARY -- ONE TWENTY TWENTY
THE DEADLINE IN THIS BILL.
WE ARE WORKING WITH CAL CHAMBER
ON AMENDMENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE --
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
I'M MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLL
EYES FORTY SIX KNOWS EIGHT THIS.
THIS MATTER PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY
NINE AB FIVE TWENTY FIVE THE
CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE FIVE TWENTY FIVE BY
SOME REMEMBER THREE OF US US AN
ACCOLADE A TEACHER CREDENTIALING.
MS RIVER AS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB FIVE TWO
FIVE IS A CLEAN UP BILL THE
MAKES A NUMBER OF NON
CONTROVERSY ALL.
OP CHANGES THAT THE COMMISSION
ON TEACHER CREDENTIALING
IDENTIFIED AS NECESSARY POLICY
UPDATES THESE CHANGES DEAL WITH
A RANGE OF SUBJECTS SUCH AS
REPLACING THE PHRASE FOREIGN
LANGUAGE WITH WORLD LANGUAGE AND
CHINESE WITH MANDARIN OR
CANTONESE.
IN ORDER TO COMPORT WITH THE
TERMINOLOGY IN USE AT OTHER
STATE AGENCIES AND WITHIN THE
WORLD LANGUAGES COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
SEEING AND HEARING NO.
MS QUIRK SILVA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS MATTER THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND I'D LIKE
TO A SUPPORT THE AUTHOR ON AB
FIVE TWO FIVE AS A FORMER
TEACHER MYSELF WE KNOW THAT SOME
OF THE STATUES THAT HAVE BEEN.
PUT INTO PRINT UR OF HAVE BEEN
IN PRINT FOR MANY MANY YEARS AND
UPDATES OR NECESSARY AND AS I
LOOKED IT WAS NOT ONLY ABOUT
LANGUAGES BUT IT'S ALSO ABOUT
WHAT TYPE OF CREDENTIALING.
TEACHERS NEED TO HAVE AND WHAT
TYPE OF UP BE A THEY HAVE AN AT
ONE OF THE STATUES SAID THAT
THEY COULD NOT HAVE A MAJOR OF I
EDUCATION AND THIS WOULD ALLOW.
EDUCATOR TO HAVE A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE IN EDUCATION WHICH KIND
OF MAKES SENSE SO I APPRECIATE
THIS UPDATING AND SUPPORT AB.
FIVE TWO FIVE THANK YOU MISS
QUIRK SILVA SERVICE YOU MAY
CLOSE ON THE MATTER.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
THE MEMBERS VOTED AS ART OF A
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE I
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO THIS BILL
PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY AB SIX
THIRTEEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX THIRTEEN BY
SOME REMEMBER LOW AN ACCOLADE
THE PROFESSIONS OF LOCATIONS IN
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE.
MR LOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MANAGE SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS
IS AB SIX THIRTEEN WHICH WOULD
ALLOW.
MORE TIME TO THE CONSUMER
AFFAIRS. TO REGULATE MAKE
MODESTY ADJUSTMENTS WITH RESPECT
ENSURING THE CONSUMER PROTECTION
FOR ALL OF CALIFORNIANS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
PLEASE VOTE.
OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO GO PLEASE
VOTE.
ALL THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
PLEASE VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE.
I FORTY SEVEN NO SIXTEEN THIS
BILL PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY ONE IS
PASTOR RETAINS MOVING TO FILE
ITEM.
ONE SEVENTY TWO AB SIX FORTY
FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ.
MIDDLE SIX FORTY FIVE BY SOME
REMEMBER IRWIN AN ACCOLADE
FIREARMS.
YES -- WHEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER?
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
MEMBERS AB SIX FOUR FIVE
REQUIRES THE POSTING OF THE
NATIONAL SUICIDE PREVENTION
LIFELINE.
ON EXISTING LABELS ON GUN
PACKAGING ON FIRES FIREARM
SAFETY -- CERTIFICATION EXAMS
AND ON NEW SIGNS AND GUN SHOPS.
THERE HAVE BEEN A STARTLING
INCREASE IN FIREARM SUICIDES IN
CALIFORNIA AND CURRENTLY THERE
IS NO MANDATED INFORMATION ON
SUICIDE PREVENTION RESOURCES.
AT ANY POINT DURING THE PROCESS
OF OBTAINING A FIREARM.
THE IDEA FOR THIS BILL CAME TO
ME FROM A VETERAN AND A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER IN VENTURA
COUNTY.
AND I AM PROUD TO BE OFFERING
HIS LEGISLATIVE IDEA.
THE BILL PASSED THE ASSEMBLY
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
UNANIMOUSLY.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR DR OF THANK YOU MISS IRWIN.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL THOSE WHO DESIRE TO GO
PLEASE VOTE.
ALL THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL THOSE WHO DESIRED -- PLEASE
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE WRONG
TALLY THE VOTE.
I FIFTY SIX KNOWS ONE THIS BILL
PASSES.
FILE ITEMS ONE SEVENTY THREE AND
ONE SEVENTY FOUR OUR PASTOR
RETAINS MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY FIVE AB THIRTEEN NINETY
THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE THIRTY NINETY BY
SOME A MEMBER MARK STONE
ACTUALLY INTO THE VERSION.
MR STONE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
MEMBERS THERE CURRENTLY IS A
PILOT PROGRAM IT SHOULD A
TRANSITIONAL AGE YOUTH PILOT
PROGRAM IN A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
COUNTIES.
THAT IT PROVIDED SOME DIVERSION
FOR YOUTH AND ALL THIS DOES IS
AN EXPANSION.
OF ITS CURRENTLY APPLIES TO
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY ONE WE'RE
EXPANDING THAT TO TWENTY FIVE IN
ACCORDANCE WITH CURRENT SCIENCE
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION THIS BILL
WE'RE JUST MAKING SURE WE'RE
COLLECTING AS MUCH DATA AS WE
CAN.
AND PROVIDING PATHS FOR YOUTH
INVOLVED IN THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES
THAT THEY HAVE GOING TO
REHABILITATION AND COME BACK
INTO SOCIETY AS A PRODUCTIVE
MANNER.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTES.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL THOSE WHO DESIRE TO GO
PLEASE VOTE.
ALL THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
THE CLERK WELL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE.
ICE FIFTY ONE KNOWS FIFTEEN THIS
BILL PASSES.
FILE ITEMS ONE SEVENTY SIX AND
ONE SEVENTY SEVEN OR PASS RETAIN
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY
EIGHT AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY TWO
THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME LEGAL FOURTEEN SEVENTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MARK STONE
ACRYLATE TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
MR STONE YOUR AGAIN RECOGNIZED
OPEN THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
IS GOING THROUGH A PROCESS OF
TRYING TO LOOK AT WHAT REPORTS
ARE BEING WE HAVE REQUIRED AN
UNDERSTAFFED SHOOT.
OF THE LAST NUMBER OF YEARS.
THIS IS A REPORT THAT HAS SOME
VALUE BUT THE STATURE IT
REQUIRES A COMMITTEE THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WHICH IS WE
WE FEEL IS NO LONGER NECESSARY
HOWEVER IT IS RELEVANT TO THE
PRIVACY COMMITTEE THIS CHANGE
MERELY.
SHIFTS THE STAFF FOR OBLIGATION
IS THAT IF YOU JUST DECIDED TO
PRIVACY I ASK YOUR AYE VOTES.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL THOSE WHO DESIRED -- PLEASE
VOTE.
ALL THOSE WHO DESIRE TO GO
PLEASE VOTE.
ALL THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE.
I SEVENTY NO ZERO THIS BILL
PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY NINE IS
PASSED TO RETAIN FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY AB ELEVEN HUNDRED THE
CLERK WILL READ.
SOME LIBERAL LEVIN HUNDRED BY
SOME REMEMBER KAMLAGER-DOVE OF
AN ACT RELATING TO ELECTRIC
VEHICLES.
THIS KAMLAGER-DOVE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I AM
PRESENTING ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
HUNDRED WHICH WILL ALIGN.
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING CODE
WITH LOCAL PARKING ORDINANCES TO
SUPPORT ELECTRIC VEHICLE EVEY
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE
CURRENTLY WHEN AN EEVEE CHARGING
STATION IS INSTALLED AS A
PARKING SPACE THE BUILDING CODE
DEFINES EXPLICITLY THAT IT IS A
CHARGING SPOT.
AND NO LONGER A PARKING SPOT.
BUILDING AN ADDITIONAL PARKING
SPACES OFTEN COSTLIER
TECHNICALLY IN FEASIBLE CAUSING
CHARGING PROJECTS TO BE DROPPED
ENTIRELY IF NOT STALLED SUCH
TECHNICAL ISSUES CREE ARBITRARY
BARRIERS TO STATION DEPLOYMENT
WHICH IS INCONSISTENT WITH THE
STATE'S LONG TERM CLIMATE GOALS.
WE KNOW THAT PARKING SPACES CAN
ALSO BE CHARGING STATIONS WE
ALSO KNOW THAT SOME
MUNICIPALITIES ARE DOING THIS
BUT THIS WOULD MAKE SOME
TECHNICAL CORRECTIONS AND ALLOW
THAT OTHER MUNICIPALITIES TO
TAKE SUCH MEASURES AS WELL.
I I ALSO WANT TO MENTION THAT AB
ELEVEN HUNDRED PASSED OUT OF
ASSEMBLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS KAMLAGER-DOVE
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE.
I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO THIS BILL
PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE ANYONE IS PASSED
AND RETAINS MOVING TO FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTY TWO AC ARE FIFTY NINE
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FIFTY NINE BY SOME REMEMBER
GRAYSON RELATIVE TO AUTISM.
MR GRAYSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
TO INTRODUCE ACR. FIFTY NINE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND SUPPORT THE
EXPANSION OF SENSORY FRIENDLY
MOVIE SCREENINGS FOR THOSE WITH
AUTISM OR SOME OF THE CONDITIONS.
OVER THREE POINT FIVE MILLION
AMERICANS LIVE ON THE AUTISM
SPECTRUM INCLUDING THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS MANY OF
THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE UNABLE TO
ENJOY AN EVENING AT THE THEATER
WITH THEIR FAMILIES UNDER THE
TRADITIONAL THEATER CONDITIONS.
AS AUTISM AWARENESS AND
EDUCATION INCREASES THE
INTERCEPT A GUN TO HOLD SO THREE
FRIENDLY FILM SCREENINGS THE
SCREENINGS TURN THE VOLUME DOWN
AND THE LIGHTS UP. TO PROVIDE A
MORE COMFORTABLE AND ACCEPTING
ENVIRONMENT FOR INDIVIDUALS ON
THE AUTISM SPECTRUM FAMILIES ARE
ALSO ALLOWED TO BRING THEIR OWN%
SNACKS IN ORDER TO COMPLY WITH
DIETARY NEEDS.
THE SCREENINGS GIVE AUDIENCE
MEMBERS THE FREEDOM TO GET UP
WALK AROUND DANCE AND CHAT WITH
FAMILY MEMBERS WITHOUT HAVING TO
WORRY ABOUT NOISE RELATED
COMPLAINTS.
THEY ARE A SAFE PLACE FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH AUTISM TO ENJOY
THE LATEST MOVIES IN THEATERS.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO SET A
POSITIVE EXAMPLE AND SHOW
SUPPORT FOR OUR FRIENDS AND OUR
FAMILY MEMBERS WITH AUTISM.
AND FOR THIS REASON I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND ASK FOR FIRST REAL CALL
TO BE OPENED UP CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISTER GRAYSON MISTER
FRAZIER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER -- MEMBERS AND I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM CONCORD
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD I'VE
ACTUALLY HOSTED TWO OF THE
SCREENING SO ONE IN BACK OF BILL
AND ONE IN.
A BROWN WOOD AND THE RESULTS
WERE ABSOLUTELY AMAZING THE
FAMILIES ARE ABLE TO RELAX IN A
SETTING THAT IS.
A NORMAL TO THEM.
AND IT'S JUST BEEN A WONDERFUL
EXPERIENCE.
I I I ABSOLUTE URGE YOU TO TALK
TO YOUR LOCAL THEATERS AND ASK
THEM TO DO THAT'S FOR YOUR
POPULATION OF OF SPECIAL NEEDS.
ADULTS AND CHILDREN.
IT'S SO IT'S SO REAFFIRMING SO
ALMOST LIKE CHRISTMAS WHEN I'M
THERE WITH THEM I CAN'T THINK OF
THIS OFFER MR -- MY COLLEAGUE
FROM CONCORD -- THAT -- THIS IS
SO EXCITING TO DO AND DOING THIS
RESOLUTION IS AN AMAZING DAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER MISTER
GRAYSON IS ASK FOR THE FIRST
ROLE TO BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS VOTE IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
THERE ARE SEVENTY CO AUTHORS ON
THIS MATTER WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE.
ON THIS RESOLUTION ALL IN FAVOR
AYE.
ALL OPPOSED NO.
IT'S MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM.
ONE EIGHTY THREE ACR SIXTY THREE
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SIXTY THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOLEY AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
CHILD ABUSE PREVENTION MONTH.
MR COOLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
COLLEAGUES I'M VERY PLEASED TO
BRING ACR SIXTY THREE TWO TWO
TODAY.
THIS MEASURE RELATES TO A SOMBER
TOPIC CHILD ABUSE PREVENTION
MONTH.
AND THEN I'LL SEE COLLEAGUES I
THIS MEASURE RELATES TO A GREAT
PUBLIC POLICY SUCCESS STORY.
CHILD ABUSE PREVENTION IS NOT A
TOPIC THAT CALIFORNIA ADDRESS
SYSTEMATICALLY BEFORE.
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO THE WHOLE
CONCEPT OF TAKING SOME SORT OF
DESTRUCTIVE BEHAVIOR.
AND ON A WHOLESALE BASIS
STATEWIDE IN ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES SUPPORTING PREVENTION
PROGRAMS.
THIS HAD NOT BEEN DONE.
STARTED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE IN AN
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN UNDER JERRY
BROWN.
PASSED LEGISLATION TO FUND CHILD
ABUSE PREVENTION NOTWITHSTANDING
ANY ECONOMIC DOWNTURN AND FOCUS
ON PREVENTION.
ON SOMETHING THAT PUTS TO REST
EVERY CHILD IN CALIFORNIA.
TODAY.
WE NOW HAVE A ROBUST SYSTEM A
CHILD WHICH PREVENTION PROGRAMS
AND ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES.
AND THE NEED REMAIN STRONG.
NEARLY HALF A MILLION CASES OF
SUSPECTED CHILD ABUSE WERE FILED
IN CALIFORNIA.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THAT'S FIVE
ALMOST FIVE HAVE PERCENT OF OUR
KIDS.
OF THESE APPROXIMATELY. SEVENTY
ONE THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED WERE
FOUND TO BE VICTIMS OF ABUSE OR
NEGLECT.
MEETING OF THE 5% 14% WERE FOUND.
TO HAVE BEEN MALTREATED.
WE EVEN IN THAT YEAR TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SAW A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THREE KIDS WHO DIED.
AS A CONSEQUENCE OF ABUSE.
IT'S STILL PREVENTION DOES WORK.
AND IT HELPS ESTABLISH A BULWARK
THAT KIDS CAN GET HELP FROM. ONE
OF OUR BEST PROGRAMS IN THIS
AREA PREVENTION ARCH FAMILY
RESOURCE CENTERS.
THESE PLAY A HUGE ROLE IN
EDUCATED PREVENTED ABUSE AND
NEGLECT.
BY BEING COMMUNITY BASED AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL.
FAMILY FOCUSED AND CULTURALLY
SENSITIVE.
ACR SIXTY THREE CALLS ON THE
PEOPLE SAY THE CALIFORNIA WORK
TOGETHER TO SUPPORT.
SUCH CHILD ABUSE OF RICHARD
PROGRAMS AND IT MAKES IT FOLKS
ON THIS AS A MONTHS LONG.
EMPHASIS.
JOIN ME IN RECOGNIZING PARTS OF
THIS ISSUE AND DESIGNATED THIS
MONTH IS CHILD ABUSE PREVENTION
MONTH.
AND I DO INTEND THAT THE FIRST
WILL BE OPEN FOR COAL AUTHORS I
KNOW I HAVE -- COLLEAGUES IN FOR
MAY SPEAK TO THIS AS WELL.
THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY MISTER
DALI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE IS A JOINT AUTHORED A C.
R. SIXTY THREE RECOGNITION IN
APRIL TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AS
CHILD ABUSE PREVENTION MONTH.
AS A FATHER I KNOW THAT CHILDREN
OUR FUTURE AND WE MUST DO
EVERYTHING TO PROTECT THEM.
AS A CASE SUPERVISOR WE WORK TO
DEVELOP FAMILY RESOURCE CENTERS
WITH THE FIRST FIVE COMMISSION
AND PROVIDED SERVICES FAMILIES
WHO NEEDED THEM AS WELL AS
WORKING WITH PARENTS.
AND AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS TO
ENSURE KIDS HAD A SAFE PLACE. TO
GO AFTER SCHOOL THEIR
APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY ONE
THOUSAND CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA
WHO ARE VICTIMS OF ABUSE OR
NEGLECT IN. 200-017-0030 THREE
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA HAVE DIED.
AS A RESULT OF CHILD ABUSE OR
NEGLECT.
THERE'S STILL A LOT OF WORK TO
BE DONE.
BUT WE ENCOURAGE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA TO WORK TOGETHER TO
SUPPORT ABUSE AND PREVENTION
PLEASE JOIN ME IN.
SUPPORTING A C. R. SIXTY THREE
RECOGNIZING A CHILD ABUSE
RECOGNITION NOT.
THANK YOU MISTER DALI MISS
EGGMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
MEMBERS I RISE IT IN SUPPORT OF
ACR SIXTY THREE BY MR COOLEY
CHILD ABUSE PREVENTION MONTH.
AND I'D ALSO ENCOURAGE ALL OF US
TO GO AND VISIT ARE COUNTING
BIZARRE COUNTY SOCIAL WORKERS
VISIT OUR CPS ON THE FRONTLINE --
AND TALK TO THEM ABOUT THEIR
WORK AND THEIR SERVICES AND
THEIR CASELOADS I SHOULD BE
ABOUT ONE SOCIAL WORKER FOR
EVERY FIFTEEN KIDS AND WE KNOW
SOMETIMES THAT IS DOUBLED
TRIPLED QUADRUPLED.
AND SO AS WE ASK A SOCIAL
REQUIRING KEEP KIDS SAFE WHEN
THEY WERE GOING OUT AND DOING
THOSE VISITS AT HOME WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THEY ARE FULLY
RESOURCE TO WE CAN KEEP EVERYONE
OF OUR CHILDREN SAFE MEMBERS.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON A C.
R. SIXTY THREE AND PLEASE GO OUT
AND VISIT YOUR LOCAL SOCIAL
WORKERS AND TALK TO THEM ABOUT
THE WORK THEY'RE DOING.
THANK YOU MISS EGGMAN.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER MISTER
COOLEY MY CLOTHES.
YES I REQUEST THE FIRST ROLL
BUILT FOR COAL AUTHORS I THINK
YOU FOR CONSIDERATION.
TO FOCUS ON APRIL IS CHILD ABUSE
PREVENTION MONTH.
THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY IS
ASKING THAT THE FIRST ROLE BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THIS VOTE IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE.
THERE ARE SEVENTY ONE CO AUTHORS
ON ACR SIXTY THREE WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ONTHIS MATTER ALL IN FAVOR
I ALL OPPOSED NO.
A C. R. SIXTY THREE PASSES MR
COOLEY YOU ARE AGAIN RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GUEST INTRODUCTION.
YES COLLEAGUES I'M DELIGHTED
INTRODUCE OF MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY RESOURCE
ASSOCIATION.
WHO ARE HERE TODAY AND SUPPORT
PLEASE STAND?
I WE HAVE JENNIFER MCVEIGH.
JENNIFER CENTOS CHARADE BOLTON
AND PRINTED DIAZ AND I THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE AND FOR YOUR WORK
ON BEHALF OF OUR STATE'S
CHILDREN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MOVING TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE EIGHTY FOUR AB FIVE
THIRTY THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE FIVE THIRTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AND
OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO THE
FEDERAL SO SOON SEWER DISTRICT
IN THE CLEARLY YEARS HERE OF
THICK THICK MEDIALLY.
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB FIVE THIRTY IS A DISTRICT
BILL THAT ALLOWS THE FAIRFIELD
TO SOON SEWER DISTRICT TO EXTEND
THEIR SERVICES. TO THE MIDDLE
GREEN VALLEY IF APPROVED BY
LAUGH GO MAKES MINOR CHANGES TO
THEIR ENABLING ACT MIDDLE GREEN
VALLEY'S UNINCORPORATED LANDING
SOLANO COUNTY WITH THE COUNTY
APPROVED THE DEVELOPMENT OF FOUR
HUNDRED NEW HOMES.
IN ORDER FOR THE SEWAGE DISTRICT
TO SERVICE THESE HOMES THEY MUST
TAKE MAKE CHANGES TO THE
ENABLING ACT REAL LEGISLATION.
AB FIVE THIRTY DOES THAT JUST
THAT THIS BILL HAS RECEIVE
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THIS MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO THE
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE A THE
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLLING TALLY THE VOTE
I SEVENTY ONE NO.
ZERO THIS BILL PASSES.
ON YOUR TO SEE AND ON THE BILL.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM.
ONE EIGHTY FIVE AB FIVE EIGHTY
SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO LAND USE.
MS FRIEDMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THIS
BILL CREATES A NARROW EXEMPTION
FOR NONPROFIT HOUSING DEVELOPERS
SUCH AS HABITAT FOR HUMANITY. TO
BE ABLE TO SUBDIVIDE A
RESIDENTIAL SINGLE FAMILY LOT
FOR THE PURPOSE OF EITHER
RENTING OR SELLING AND EIGHTY
YOU.
ARE THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT
STARTED IN SANTA CRUZ WITH
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY WAS VERY
SUCCESSFUL BUT WHEN OTHER YOU
MINUTE MUNICIPALITIES TRY TO
COPY IT THEY FOUND OUT THAT IN
MANY AREAS IT'S ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE IF NOT DOWNRIGHT
IMPOSSIBLE TO DO THIS.
BECAUSE OF EXISTING SUBDIVISION
LAWS AND TAXING LAWS THIS
CREATES THE SANTA CRUZ --
PROGRAM STATEWIDE FORD
NONPROFITS AND FOR
MUNICIPALITIES THAT WANT TO
PARTICIPATE IT'S A GREAT WAY TO
ENCOURAGE HOMEOWNERSHIP IT'S A
GREAT WAY TO CAPITALIZE ON
SINGLE FAMILY LOTS -- FOR FOR
AFFORDABLE RENTALS AND THIS BILL
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN AND
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT OF BOTH OF ITS
COMMITTEES AND I REQUEST REALLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS FRIEDMAN'S SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
THAT.
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLAND
TALLY THE VOTE I SEVENTY ONE NO
ZERO THIS BILL PASSES.
FILE ITEMS ONE EIGHTY SIX ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN ONE EIGHTY EIGHT OR
PASSED THE ROUTINES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY
NINE AB TWELVE EIGHTY ONE THE
CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE TWELVE EIGHTY ONE BY
SOME REMEMBER CHAO ANOTHER SNACK
LATER PRIVACY.
MR CHOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
AB TWELVE EIGHTY ONE WOULD
INFORM.
CUSTOMERS WITH A POSTED SIGN OF
A CALIFORNIA BUSINESS IS USING
FACIAL RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY OR
F. R. T. WHICH IS THE
APPLICATION OF BIOMETRIC
SOFTWARE USED TO AUTOMATICALLY
IDENTIFY AN INDIVIDUAL FROM A
DIGITAL IMAGE.
OR VIDEO FRAMES.
THE TECHNOLOGY IS BECOMING EVER
MORE THE PRESIDENT THROUGHOUT
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA AND
CONCERNS OF PRIVACY AND USE OF
THE INFORMATION ARE INCREASING.
IN FACT A NEW STUDY RAISES
BROADER QUESTIONS OF FAIRNESS
AND ACCOUNTABILITY IN REGARDS TO
THE MACHINE LEARNING ALGORITHMS
THAT ARE THE FOUNDATION OF F. R.
T. ESPECIALLY AT A TIME.
WHEN INVESTING IN ADOPTION OF
THE TECHNOLOGY IS RAISING AHEAD?
AB TWELVE EIGHTY ONE WAS SIMPLY
MAKE CONSUMERS AWARE OF WHICH
BUSINESSES ARE YOU SURE USING
FACIAL RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY.
A RECENT AMENDMENTS ARE REMOVED
ALL OPPOSITION THE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAO MISTER
DALI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
MATTER YES I HAVE A QUESTION THE
AUTHOR PLEASE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SO WHERE DOES
THE FINE MONEY -- I LOOKED IN
THE BILL COULDN'T FIND OUT WHERE
THE FINE MONEY GOES -- WHAT WHAT
HAPPENS TO THE FINES?
ALTHOUGH THE LAW DOESN'T
CURRENTLY DEFINED WHAT THAT --
SIGN HAS TO GO BAD AS LONG AS
IT'S A A CONSPICUOUS AND VISIBLE
AT THE STOREFRONT IT DOES THE
VICES FOR A PURPOSE OF THE LAW.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
THE THIRD.
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE.
ICE FIFTY FIVE NEWS TWELVE THIS
BILL PASSES
.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE NINETY
AB EIGHT EIGHTY THE CLERK WILL
READ.
SOME PEOPLE EIGHT EIGHTY BY SOME
MEMBER OBERNOLTE AN ACCOLADE
TRANSPORTATION.
MR OBERNOLTE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AB EIGHT EIGHTY IS
A CODE CLEAN UP BILL A DELETE
SEVERAL OBSOLETE REFERENCES IN
THE STATE PUBLIC UTILITY CODE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE A
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN.
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
VOTE -- MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
THE CLERK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THIS BILL PASSES.
FILE ITEMS NUMBER ONE NINETY ONE
WHEN I NEED TO OUR PASTOR RETAIN
MOVING TO FILE.
ITEM ONE NINETY THREE AB ELEVEN
FORTY FOR THE CLERK WILL READ.
SO WE BILL ELEVEN FORTY FOUR BY
SOME MEMBER FRIEDMAN AND OTHERS
AN ACCOLADE TO ELECTRICITY.
THIS FRIEDMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I'M PROUD PERCENT
AB ELEVEN FORTY FOUR WHICH
REQUIRES CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
UTILITY COMMISSION. TO USE 10%
OF THE EXISTING SELF GENERATION
INCENTIVE PROGRAM FUNDS FROM
TWENTY TWENTY TO BE ALLOCATED
TOWARDS CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
IN HIGH FIRE SEVERITY ZONES.
WE NOTE THAT TO REDUCE THE RISK
OF FIRE OF WILDFIRES IN HIGH
FIRE SORORITIES OWNS WE'RE GOING
TO BE DE ENERGIZING POWER LINES
AND THAT LEADS.
COMMUNITIES CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE WITHOUT POWER AT
TIMES WHEN THEY OFTEN NEED IT
THE MOST THIS WOULD SHIFT MONEY
THAT ALREADY EXISTS TO USE FOR
SELF GENERATION AND STORAGE INTO
THOSE AREAS.
SO THAT WE CAN PROTECT CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE WHEN WE DE
ENERGIZED LINES THIS BILL IS
RESTRICT RECEIVED STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND NO NO
VOTES AS FAR AS I REMEMBER IT
ANY OF ITS COMMITTEES AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE -- A ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLEAR WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE SIZE SEVENTY TO THE NO
ZERO THIS BILL PASSES.
FILE ITEMS ONE NINETY FOUR
THROUGH -- ONE NINETY SEVEN
PASTOR RETAINS [inaudible]
OKAY.
THE FIRST.
MOVING TO A VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FILE ITEMS TO OWES
THREE THREE TWO FORTY TWO DOES
ANY MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND A
CONSENT CALENDAR SOME PEOPLE
FOURTEEN THIRTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DALLYING ACCOLADE
WATER.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE USER WILL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE.
I SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
FURTHER READING OF THE REMAINING
CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS.
WE HAVE ONE ADDITIONAL GUEST
INTRODUCTION MISTER LEVINE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUEST
INTRODUCTION.
YOU MADAM SPEAKER WE'VE GOT
NINETY HIGH SCHOOL SENIORS FROM
PETALUMA'S CASA GRANDE THIS
YESTERDAY WITH THEIR TEACHER
LEASE A CANE AND A FEW
CHAPERONES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING AND
JOINING US AT THE CAPITOL GO
GOTCHA.
MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS THE
FOLLOWING COMMITTEES WILL MEET
UPON ADJOURNMENT OBSESSION
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE IN ROOM
FOUR FOUR SEVEN ELECTIONS AND
REDISTRICTING COMMITTEE IN ROOM.
FOUR FOUR FOUR HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE
IN ROOM ONE TWO SIX JUDICIARY IN
THE RULES COMMITTEE ROOM.
THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS NO FLOOR SESSION OR
CHECK IN SESSION ON FRIDAY APRIL.
TWENTY SIX AND WE'LL HAVE FLOOR
SESSION AT ONE PM ON MONDAY
APRIL.
TWENTY NINE IN THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED AND WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
THE PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR
.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR
.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON IN GERMANY MEMORY.
MISS GARCIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU.
I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OVER OLD ANTONIO GET AYE
WHO SERVED IN THE NAVY AS A
JOURNALIST AND LEFT FOR VIETNAM
IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN LESS THAN A
YEAR INTO HIS EMPLOYMENT KERO
WAS KILLED ALONG WITH FOUR
OTHERS IN A PLANE CRASH.
HIS REMAINS WERE NEVER RECOVERED
UNTIL NOW FIFTY TWO YEARS LATER.
IT WAS ACTUALLY THE TIRELESS
WORK BY HIS BEST FRIEND REUVEN
VALENCIA WHO LAST SAW HIM AT THE
AGE OF EIGHTEEN YEARS OLD.
MR VIOLENCE I WORKED WITH
DEFENSE P. O. W. MIA ACCOUNTING
AGENCY TO FINALLY LOCATE HIS
FRIENDS REMAINS.
WELL INTO ANGER ARE PRESENT WHEN
THEY WERE ELEVEN YEARS OLD
ATTENDING SCHOOL IN MONTEBELLO.
BOTH BOYS WERE BEING RAISED BY
SINGLE MOTHERS.
WHO WORKED FULL TIME SO THEY
BECAME QUICK AND BEST FRIEND?
VIOLENCE YES THERE THAT'S A
MARINE IN VIETNAM BUT HIMSELF
WHEN TO PROPERLY IDENTIFY HIS
FRIEND THEM FAMILY FINALLY.
HIS FRIEND FINALLY BRINGING HIM
HOME.
ROLL WILL FINALLY BE BURIED THIS
WEEK AT ROSEHILL CEMETERY IN
WHITTIER WHICH VIOLENCE VACANCY
FROM HIS BACKYARD.
OTHER VETERANS HAVE HELPED HER
TO THE GRAVE SITE.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN THANKING ROLE
FOR HIS ULTIMATE SERVICE TO THIS
COUNTRY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS GARCIA.
PLEASE BRING THE NAME TO THE
DESK TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL OUR QUEST TO JOURNEY
MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER WRITINGS IS REMAINING
WE PASSED A RETAINED ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MR DEEP MOVES AND MISS GONZALEZ
SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY APRIL
TWENTY NINTH AT ONE PM
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
SO MAYBE -- FOR THIRTY NINE WITH
URGENCY I SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO
FIVE SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO BUT
THE URGENCY AND THE BILL.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR SIXTY FIVE I
SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO SUM A BILL
SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN I SEVENTY
FOUR NO ZERO SOME LITTLE
THIRTEEN THIRTY SIX FIVE SEVENTY
FOUR NO ZERO SOMEONE REALLY
SIXTY NINE FIVE SEVENTY FOUR
KNOWS ZERO SOME PEOPLE FOURTEEN
TWENTY NINE I SEVENTY FOUR NO.
ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FIFTY
FIVE I SEVENTY FOUR KNOWS ZERO
SUM ZERO FOUR FOUR I SEVENTY
FOUR NEWS ZERO SOMETHING BEFORE
TWELVE FIVE SEVENTY FOUR NEWS
ZERO SOME PEOPLE FOR TWENTY TWO
I SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO SYMBOL
FOR FIFTY I SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO
SOME PEOPLE FOR FIFTY SIX FIVE
SEVENTY FOUR NO. ZERO SENATE
BILL FIVE FORTY FIVE I SEVENTY
FOUR NEWS ZERO SOME PEOPLE FIVE
SIXTY FIVE I SEVENTY FOUR NEWS
ZERO SOME PEOPLE TO EIGHTEEN I
SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO CORRECTION
ASSEMBLY BILL.
SIX THIRTY I SEVENTY FOUR NO
ZERO SOME PEOPLE SIX NINETY I
SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE
SEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT I SEVENTY
FOUR NO ZERO SOME LEGAL SEVEN
EIGHTY TWO I SEVENTY FOUR KNOWS
ZERO SOME LEGAL IT'LL FUN HI
SEVENTY FOUR NO. ZERO EIGHT
FORTY FIVE I SEVENTY FOUR NO
ZERO SUM ZERO EIGHT NINETY SIX
FIVE SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO SOME
PEOPLE NINE OH TWO I SEVENTY
FOUR NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE NINE OH
NINE I SEVENTY FOUR NEWS ZERO
SOME PEOPLE NINE THIRTEEN I
SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO SUM AGO.
NINE SIXTEEN FIVE SEVENTY FOUR
NO ZERO SOME LITTLE KNOWN TWENTY
FIVE FIVE SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO
SOMETHING GOING ON FORTY SEVEN I
SEVENTY FOUR KNOWS.
SOME PEOPLE NINE SEVENTY THREE I
SEVENTY FOUR KNOWS ZERO
SOMETHING BILL TEN NINETY NINE I
SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE
FIFTEEN NINETY SEVEN I SEVENTY
FOUR NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE SIXTEEN
THIRTY THREE I SEVENTY FOUR
KNOWS ZERO CYNICAL SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY I SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO
SOME OF BILL. SIX THIRTY TWO I
SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION THIRTY
EIGHT I SEVENTY FOUR KNOWS
SOMETHING CURRENT RESOLUTION
FORTY SEVEN FIVE SEVENTY FOUR NO.
ZERO SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION TWENTY THREE I
SEVENTY FOUR NEWS ZERO SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION TWENTY
FOUR ICE SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO
CID THE CURRENT RESOLUTION
TWENTY SEVEN I SEVENTY FOUR
KNOWS ZERO AND CITY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION.
THIRTY THREE I SEVENTY FOUR NO